aunque llegó a un acuerdo económico
sustancial con virginia geoffrei para
evitar un juicio civil en una corte de
nueva york es poco probable que el
príncipe andrés recupere sus honores y
sus títulos militares así como sus
funciones públicas dentro de la familia
real británica este anuncio del acuerdo
es visto aquí en el reino unido como un
motivo de alivio no solamente para
andrés para la familia real británica
sino especialmente para la reina isabel
que celebra este año los 70 años en el
trono y estas acusaciones estaban
eclipsando ese récord sin embargo la
reputación del príncipe andrés el duque
de york estaba completamente destrozada
por esas acusaciones de supuesto abuso
sexual a una menor hecho que él ha
desmentido en repetidas ocasiones el
príncipe andrés también se ha
comprometido a demostrar su
arrepentimiento por su asociación por el
condenado pederasta jeffrey epstein de
quien andrew era amigo cercano
probablemente nunca conoceremos los
detalles completos de este acuerdo ni
como se llegó a él pero desde ya se
reporta que andrew pagará entre 5 y 10
millones de dólares a la organización de
caridad de virgin a geoffrey que vela y
protege a las víctimas del abuso sexual